justement Lucas on va rester à la mairie
tour o on a parlé budget aujourd'hui oui
le conseil municipal réuni aujourd'hui a
débattu des orientations budgétaires de
l'année à venir le fil rouge l'inflation
et cette volonté de faire baisser la
dette de la ville l'an prochain tour va
procéder à un remboursement de 31
millions d'euros pardon d'emprunt pour
cela la mairie propose notamment
d'accentuer la sobriété énergétique tour
en gel en parallèle elle mise sur des
investissements vertueux record Aurélie
Renaud tour veut remettre en état le
patrimoine de la ville et ses
équipements en 2024 45 millions d'euros
seront investis sur le territoire
plusieurs rénovations comme celle des
écoles du patronnage Laï paulbert
l'accessibilité PMR du centre municipal
des sports ou encore la toiture du Musée
des Beaux Arts pendant très longtemps la
ville de tour a été pénalisée par sa
datte financière qui l'empêchait
d'investir dans son patrimoine et on a
décidé de cesser cette spirale qui était
une spirale négative à cercle vicieux
pour pour le faire rentrer dans un
cercle vertueux et pour ça il fallait
impérativement relancer l'investissement
et c'est le choix fort qui a été fait
par notre municipalité c'est d'aller
rénover tout ce qui a besoin d'être
rénové alors ce sera long hein parce que
pendant plus de 30 ans la ville a été en
sous-investissement chronique
c'est-à-dire qu'elle investissait 30 %
de moins qu'Ang ou Orléan laisser
repartir la dette une décision qui fait
frémir l'opposition pour Christophe
boucher il faut faire des choix exemple
réduire les frais de fonctionnement de
la
mairie ils nous ont communiqué les
chiffres d'embauche net qui sont de plus
de 100 personnes sur d'une année sur
l'autre he c'est pas rien donc quand on
combine les deux c'est l'augmentation du
nombre de personnes qui travaillent plus
plus les augmentations qu'on doit leur
donner ça fait des chiffres importants
et c'est des chiffres surtout qui vont
se répercuter sur plusieurs décennies
parce que quand on embauche quelqu'un la
ville de tour c'est un fonctionnaire et
on l'embauche pour 30 35 ans Benoît
Pierre lui reproche à la majorité de ne
pas vouloir désendetter la ville en
ayant l'ambition par exemple d'aller
chercher des financements nouveaux vous
avez ce qu'on appelle la dette verte
c'està-dire la mise à disposition à
venir de
crédits d'emprunt qui vont être à des
taux très très concurrentiels pour
permettre de d'investir dans dans ce
domaine ça aujourd'hui la ville est en
impréparation par rapport à cela enfin
concernant la dette la majorité
municipale indique qu'en 2024 elle sera
sur un record tion de la dette avec 31
millions d'euros
remboursés